the news came as no surprise president
Alberto Fernandez announced on Friday
that he won't run for re-election in
October this year
Fernandez revealed the news on his
social media where he published a seven
minute video explaining his struggles as
president of Argentina and why he'd made
the decision
on December 10 2023 on the same day in
which we celebrate 40 Years of democracy
I will give the presidential ban to
whoever has been elected by the popular
vote I will work so that this is someone
from our political space
Alberto Fernandez came to power in 2019.
he was hand-picked by one of the most
powerful politicians in the country
former president Christina Fernandez
kirschner
Christina as people call her needed a
moderate candidate to run as president
with her as vice president
but since taking office the peronis
Coalition did not work out with enormous
differences surfacing between the
president and vice president on how to
run the country
now many are wondering who the peronist
candidate will be in the presidential
elections
Christina is allowing everyone to talk
until she comes out and defines things
the way she wants to there is no real
discussion Christina will Define the
strategy she will Define who will be the
candidate the 65 percent of the country
that wants to vote against Christina is
still trying to find a candidate that is
strong enough and that'll be able to
solve the economic troubles that exist
whomever wins the elections won't have
an easy job the announcement by
President Alberto Fernandez happens just
as this country is in the middle of our
economic crisis with over 100 percent
inflation in the past year with capital
controls where the government sets an
official exchange rate but be an
official exchange rate is going up every
day we're here on the streets where
several shops are for example setting
the different prices of the US Dollars
and it keeps on changing all the time
this is just an example of how unstable
the economy in the country is right now
the pandemic the war in Ukraine and an
unprecedented drought have complicated
Argentina's endemic economic troubles
the economic molest is felt on the
street Romina Lani says the only thing
she wants right now is stability
we are selling what we can but with
inflation it is too difficult I only
hope that whomever comes after Alberto
Fernandez will do a better job Alberto
Fernandez still has some difficult
months ahead
many fear that the government's lack of
credibility May worsen the economic
situation and the lives of the millions
of people who once voted for him
Buenos Aires